ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ quantum computing in practice ตอนนี้จะโฟกัสที่ขั้นตอนแรกและมักเป็นขั้นตอนที่ท้าทาย
ที่สุดในการนิยาม quantum program คือการ map ปัญหาทั่วไปไปยัง circuit ที่รันบน quantum
computer ได้ ขั้นตอนนี้อธิบายว่าผู้ใช้ที่เริ่มต้นด้วยปัญหาการคำนวณที่กำหนดให้
สามารถแปลมันเพื่อให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้อย่างไร
ในบทเรียนก่อน ๆ ของซีรีส์นี้ บทเรียนสองและสาม เราพูดถึงว่า mapping stage เป็นขั้นตอนแรกจาก
สี่ใน Qiskit patterns framework จากบทเรียนเหล่านั้น คุณอาจจำได้ว่าเป้าหมายของเราคือการ translate
หรือเขียนปัญหาการคำนวณใหม่เป็น cost function หรือ expectation value
ที่เราสามารถ evaluate โดยใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ในบทเรียนสาม เราพูดถึงตัวอย่างเฉพาะหนึ่งกับ max cut ซึ่งเป็นปัญหาที่
ยากทางการคำนวณและพบบ่อยใน combinatorial optimization
ในตัวอย่างนั้น เราผ่านขั้นตอนหลายอย่างเพื่อแปลง graph เดิมเป็นปัญหาที่ quantum native เรา
แปลงปัญหาของการหาจำนวน cut สูงสุดใน graph เป็น cost function จากนั้นเขียน cost
function นั้นใหม่เป็น Hamiltonian และเตรียม trial quantum state ที่ ground state
สอดคล้องกับ max cut สุดท้ายเราสร้าง quantum circuit ที่แทน trial quantum state ของ
ความสนใจ และเพิ่ม gate เฉพาะเพื่อให้ state evolve ตามเวลา ลำดับขั้นตอนนี้คือสิ่งที่
เราเรียกว่า mapping และในระดับสูง กระบวนการนี้ทั่วไปสำหรับแอปพลิเคชันอื่น ๆ มากมาย เช่น quantum chemistry
และ quantum simulation ตอนนี้ไม่มีทางหลีกเลี่ยงความจริงว่า mapping อาจยาก ไม่มี
strategy ที่เหมาะกับทุกปัญหา ดังนั้นอาจน่ากลัว วันนี้ฉันจะ highlight
ตัวอย่างที่เป็นตัวแทนของปัญหาต่าง ๆ และอธิบายว่ามันถูก map อย่างไรในแต่ละกรณี ฉันจะ
ทบทวนสั้น ๆ สิ่งที่เรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับปัญหา graph เช่นที่ใช้ใน Max Cut และใช้เวลาที่เหลือของบรรยายโฟกัสที่
วิธี map ปัญหาที่ปรากฏในธรรมชาติ เช่น ปัญหาโครงสร้างโมเลกุลในชีววิทยา electronic
structure ในเคมี และการจำลอง quantum field theory ใน high energy physics
แต่ก่อนที่เราจะใช้เวลาส่วนใหญ่ในตอนนี้ดูตัวอย่างปัญหาจากวรรณกรรม ฉันอยากให้
ภาพรวมระดับสูงของสิ่งหลักที่เราต้องการทำและพิจารณาเมื่อ map ปัญหา มี
สิ่งที่ต้องพิจารณาสำหรับปัญหาการคำนวณประเภทใดก็ตามที่ต้องแปลงเป็น quantum circuit
อย่างแรก คุณอาจต้องลดความซับซ้อนปัญหาเพื่อให้เป็นไปได้ นี่เป็นเรื่องธรรมดาสำหรับวิทยาศาสตร์ส่วนใหญ่
ไม่ใช่เรื่องเฉพาะของ quantum computing ถ้าคุณเคยได้ยินสำนวน "assume a
spherical cow" มันพาดพิงถึงความจริงที่ว่ามักยากที่จะอธิบายระบบตามที่มันปรากฏ แต่
แทนที่เราสามารถทำ simplification ที่สมเหตุสมผลซึ่งยังนำไปสู่ solution ที่เป็นประโยชน์ได้
ตัวอย่างวิธีที่เราอาจทำสิ่งนี้ใน quantum computing คือการจำกัดขนาดหรือ circuit depth โดยการเลือก
hardware-efficient ansatz หรือตัด complex time evolution หรือละเลย
Hamiltonian term ที่มีส่วนน้อยต่อพลังงานสุดท้ายของ quantum state
ประเด็นถัดไปที่อยากทำคือคุณต้องคิดถึงการเขียนปัญหาในลักษณะที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้
บ่อยครั้งหมายถึงการถามสามคำถามนี้ หนึ่ง qubit ของเรา
แทนอะไรในแบบจำลองนี้? สอง ปัญหาของเราต่อเนื่องหรือไม่? เนื่องจากคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเป็นดิจิทัล คุณต้อง
หาวิธี discretise ปัญหา และสาม สุดท้าย topology ของปัญหา align กับ topology ของ
hardware หรือไม่? ถ้าใช่ ดีมาก แต่ถ้าไม่ เราอาจต้อง implement เคล็ดลับบางอย่างเพื่อให้มันทำงาน มา address
คำถามแรกนี้ สิ่งที่ฉันคิดว่าอยู่ที่หัวใจของความยากทั้งหมดในการเข้าใจ mapping โดยเฉพาะในฐานะ
แนวคิดใหม่ qubit แทนอะไรได้?
qubit สามารถใช้แทนหลายสิ่ง อย่างแรกและง่ายที่สุดในความเห็นฉันคือ node บน graph Graph ถูก
ใช้แสดง connectivity และปัญหาทางคณิตศาสตร์ประเภทต่าง ๆ มากมาย และ node เป็น element พื้นฐานที่แทน point
หรือ entity ใน network ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า network ทั้งหมดแทนอะไร อาจเป็นเมือง คน หรือ
ferromagnet ใน lattice qubit ยังสามารถใช้แทน boson และ fermion แม้ฉันจะเตือนที่นี่ว่า
qubit เดียวไม่ได้เท่ากับ boson หรือ fermion หนึ่งตัว มันซับซ้อน
กว่านั้นนิดหน่อยและจะพูดถึงในไม่ช้า แต่โดยทั่วไป chain ของ spin ที่เป็นไปตาม statistics บางอย่างเป็น
สิ่งที่แปลงเป็น qubit architecture ได้ง่าย
ตอนนี้เราเข้าสู่ตัวอย่างที่ซับซ้อนขึ้นเล็กน้อย สำหรับแบบจำลองเหล่านี้ ไม่สมเหตุสมผลอีกต่อไปที่จะ
พูดในแง่ของ qubit เดี่ยว
แทนที่เราต้องการกลุ่มของมันเพื่อสร้างบางอย่างที่เป็นรูปธรรม ตัวอย่างเช่น
กลุ่มของ qubit ที่แสดงที่นี่บน heavy hexagonal topology สามารถใช้แทนตำแหน่งทางเรขาคณิตของ amino
acid หรือ polymer chain อีกตัวอย่างคือการจำลอง hadron scattering
ใน high energy physics model ซึ่งทำได้โดยจำลอง time evolution ของ hadronic wave packet ในกรณีนี้
register ของ qubit สามารถใช้ encode state ต่าง ๆ ของ quantum field ได้ vacuum state ของ field นั้นหรือ
wave packet ที่ propagate บน vacuum นี้
ตอนนี้ฉันยังอยากสังเกตว่าการ map ปัญหาไปยังคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมีขั้นตอนที่ชัดเจน คือ หนึ่ง การ map
state ลงบน qubit และ circuit และสอง การ map cost function หรือ expectation
ของ quantum observable และ operator เราจะเห็นวิธีจัดการสิ่งเหล่านี้ในตัวอย่างเฉพาะ แต่ที่
จุดนี้เราพูดในเชิงนามธรรมเพียงพอแล้วเกี่ยวกับความท้าทายที่เผชิญ
มาดูตัวอย่างเหล่านี้อย่างละเอียดตอนนี้
มาเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างแรก ในความเห็นของฉัน หนึ่งในปัญหา mapping ที่ง่ายที่สุดคือสิ่งที่เราได้
พูดถึงในเชิงลึกแล้ว นั่นคือตัวอย่าง max cut ในปัญหานั้น การ mapping ค่อนข้างง่ายสำหรับเรา เพราะ qubit หนึ่ง
เท่ากับ node หนึ่งบน graph การใช้ node บน graph เข้าใจง่ายมากและ
โชคดีที่สอดคล้องกับแอปพลิเคชันมากมาย บ่อยครั้งที่ต้องการ model บางอย่างที่สอดคล้องกับ
ชุด node ที่เชื่อมต่อกัน ถ้ากลุ่มเป็น binary เช่น ศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง หรือรวมและไม่รวมใน set
คุณสามารถ map node เหล่านั้นเป็น bit หรือ qubit ได้ง่าย ๆ และเป็นธรรมชาติ
ในตัวอย่างนี้ และแม้แต่ตัวอย่างที่เรา scale up เป็น 100 qubit ในตอนที่ 3 graph connectivity
ก็ตรงกับ topology ของ superconducting hardware ของเราอยู่แล้ว ดังนั้นเราไม่ต้องกังวลเรื่องนั้น แต่นั่นไม่เสมอไป
และถ้าคุณมี graph ที่ซับซ้อนกว่าหรือเชื่อมต่อมากกว่าตัวอย่างที่เราเน้น คุณจะ
ต้อง implement swap gate แต่สิ่งนี้จัดการในขั้นตอนที่สองของ Qiskit patterns ซึ่งเกี่ยวข้องกับ
transpilation อีกส่วนหนึ่งของปัญหา max cut ที่ทำให้มันสะดวกคือ
เรารู้วิธี express cost function เป็น Hamiltonian โดยใช้ QUBO formulation แล้ว
จำไว้ว่าใน quantum computing และ variational quantum algorithm Hamiltonian cost function คือ function
ที่ encode optimal solution ของปัญหาใน ground state ของ Hamiltonian
เพื่อสร้าง cost Hamiltonian เราสามารถใช้ sparse Pauli op class ใน Qiskit เพื่อระบุ
connectivity ของ graph และ mapping stage ไปยัง quantum operator ก็เสร็จแล้ว และ quantum circuit
ก็เป็นแค่ QAOA ansatz ตอนนี้ถ้าสิ่งนี้ไม่ดังในใจ กรุณากลับไปดูตอนที่ 3 ที่เรา
ดำเนินการในรายละเอียดมากขึ้น ตอนนี้มาเพิ่มความยากขึ้นเล็กน้อย ถัดไป เราจะดู
ตัวอย่างที่ model ในงานวิจัยชื่อ "Resource-Efficient Quantum Algorithm for Protein Folding" โดย
IBM ร่วมกับ University of New South Wales พื้นหลังด้านชีวเคมีเล็กน้อย Protein คือ
macromolecule ที่ประกอบด้วย chain ยาวของ amino acid chain ยาวเหล่านี้ fold
เป็นโครงสร้างที่ซับซ้อนซึ่งทำหน้าที่ทางชีววิทยาหลากหลาย
การกำหนดโครงสร้างโปรตีนใน three-dimensional space และทำความเข้าใจความสัมพันธ์ระหว่าง
โครงสร้างและหน้าที่เป็นหนึ่งในปัญหาที่ท้าทายที่สุดในวิชาชีวเคมีวันนี้
โปรตีน fold เป็นโครงสร้างที่มีประโยชน์เนื่องจาก interaction ระหว่าง amino acid เอง
เมื่อโครงสร้างบิดและ fold amino acid ที่อยู่ห่างกันบน chain อาจจบอยู่ใกล้กัน
และอาจ interact กันอย่างแรง เราต้องได้ Hamiltonian ที่อธิบาย interaction ทั้งหมดระหว่าง amino
acid ถ้าต้องการทำนายว่าโครงสร้างสุดท้ายใดจะ minimize พลังงาน ที่นี่เราจะโฟกัสที่ amino acid chain และ
วิธี model บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม และวิธีได้ inter-amino acid distance สำหรับ
การคำนวณ interaction energy
ด้วยสิ่งนี้ เราจะได้รวบรวม contribution ที่จำเป็นทั้งหมดสำหรับ Hamiltonian เพื่อจำลอง
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม ในโปรตีนจริง amino acid สามารถอยู่ใน continuum ของตำแหน่งที่เป็นไปได้
อย่างไรก็ตาม เราจะใช้ simplification ที่นี่และจำกัดมันไปยัง lattice model ที่แต่ละ amino acid
อยู่ที่จุดบน grid ที่นี่ ผู้เขียนใช้ tetrahedral lattice
หมายเหตุด่วนที่นี่ เรา encode ทิศทางของ edge ไม่ใช่ node เหมือนในปัญหา max cut
แต่ละ qubit แทน single-step path ที่เป็นไปได้ตาม tetrahedral grid สังเกตว่า adjacent site ถูก
ตั้งชื่อว่า A หรือ B ในแผนภาพนี้เนื่องจาก orientation ต่างกันใน lattice
โปรตีน chain ถูกแทนด้วยชุด turn หรือทิศทางบน
lattice นี้ แต่ละ turn ระหว่าง amino acid สามารถอยู่ในทิศทางหนึ่งในสี่ทิศทาง
ที่สอดคล้องกับ edge ของ tetrahedron
สี่ turn ที่เป็นไปได้เหล่านี้ถูก encode โดยใช้สี่ qubit
ฟังดูยุ่งยากนิดหน่อย มาดูตัวอย่างนี้ในเชิงลึกขึ้นหน่อย
มาวาง amino acid แรกของเราที่จุดนี้บน tetrahedral lattice ทิศทางไปยัง
amino acid chain แรกถึงที่สองเป็นสิ่งที่ arbitrary เพราะระบบสามารถหมุนเสมอเพื่อให้ edge ชี้ไปใน
ทิศทางที่ต้องการ ดังนั้นวาง amino acid ที่สองที่นี่ ไม่
ชัดเจนนัก แต่ path จากที่สองถึงที่สามจริง ๆ ก็ arbitrary เช่นกัน ทางเลือกทั้งสามจะ
ส่งผลให้มีสอง edge ที่มีมุมประมาณ 109.5°
ระหว่างกัน การเลือก edge ที่สองนี้เพียงแค่กำหนด orientation ของโปรตีนของเราในพื้นที่ ดังนั้นโดยไม่สูญเสีย
ทั่วไปใด ๆ เราสามารถเลือก turn แรกให้เป็นแค่ 0 0 1 และ 0 0 1
0 ด้วย simplification เหล่านี้ configuration ของ amino acid chain ถูกให้โดย expression นี้เพียงง่าย ๆ
จนถึงตอนนี้เรา map tetrahedral edge ไปยัง qubit แล้วและ quantum circuit ของเราจะเป็น ansatz ตอนนี้ต้อง
พิจารณาวิธี encode พลังงานของปัญหาเป็น Hamiltonian เพื่อให้ ground state ให้
folding pattern ที่ optimal ตอนนี้สำหรับ configuration ใด ๆ จะมีพลังงานที่เกี่ยวข้องเนื่องจาก
interaction ระหว่าง amino acid เอง interaction เหล่านี้แข็งแกร่งที่สุดเมื่อ amino acid สอง
ตัวอยู่ใกล้กัน แน่นอนว่า amino acid ที่อยู่ติดกันใน backbone ของ chain จะ interact กันเสมอ
แต่เนื่องจากโปรตีนสามารถบิดและ fold ได้ คู่ amino acid อื่น ๆ
ก็สามารถ interact ได้เช่นกัน amino acid 10 และ 20 เช่น อาจจบอยู่บน
adjacent site หลังจากโปรตีน fold แล้ว amino acid ที่จบอยู่ใกล้กันมี
interaction แรงกว่าและขับเคลื่อนกระบวนการ folding แต่ไม่ได้หมายความว่า index จะอยู่ใกล้กัน
เสมอไป ดังนั้นเราต้องสูตรเพื่ออธิบาย distance D ระหว่าง amino acid I และ
J โดยใช้ข้อมูลที่ encode บน configuration qubit วิธีนี้ทำให้
เราสามารถใช้ separation distance ของมันเพื่อกำหนดว่า interaction แรงแค่ไหน นี่ซับซ้อน
เล็กน้อย แต่อยู่กับฉัน เพราะมันเป็นเคล็ดลับที่ดี อย่างแรก มาแนะนำ function f_a ของ i ที่บ่งบอกว่า
edge a ถูกใช้สำหรับ turn ที่ amino acid i หรือไม่ โดยที่ a สามารถรับค่า
ทิศทางที่เป็นไปได้สี่ทิศทาง โดยคำนึงถึง configuration coding ด้านบน เราสามารถเขียน function เหล่านี้แล้ว
นิยาม ความแตกต่างในจำนวน turn ที่ labeled a บน A และ B lattice จาก
index I ถึง index J เป็น delta N ทำไมเราถึงทำสิ่งนี้? มันปรากฏว่า
tetrahedral lattice มีคุณสมบัติที่มีประโยชน์มาก มาโฟกัสที่ amino acid นี้ ไม่สำคัญว่าเป็นตัวไหน
แต่มาเรียกมันว่า amino acid E เราอยากรู้ว่า amino acid j อยู่ห่างแค่ไหน และสิ่งที่มีคือ
edge ตาม backbone step เริ่มจาก I สังเกตว่า step
ออกจากศูนย์กลางตาม edge ประเภทหนึ่ง เรียกว่า a จาก A lattice
site นี้ตรงข้ามกับและถูก undo โดย step ออกตาม edge a จาก
b site ดังนั้น step หลาย step ตาม edge A จาก A lattice site ใด ๆ ย้าย
backbone ออกจาก amino acid E และ step ตาม edge type A จาก B site
พากลับ ดังนั้น distance ระหว่าง amino acid สอง I และ J ตาม edge
type ที่เรา label ว่า A ขึ้นอยู่กับ ความแตกต่างระหว่าง step ที่ทำตาม A
edge จาก A site และ B site เนื่องจาก A และ B สลับกันโดยจำเป็นใน
protein backbone สิ่งนี้ถูกจับด้วย term (-1)^k และ argument นี้ใช้กับ edge type อื่น ๆ ด้วย
ดังนั้น distance ระหว่าง amino acid ใน tetrahedral lattice step สามารถคำนวณในที่สุดได้ด้วย
expression นี้ แต่เราจะได้ Hamiltonian จาก equation ยาวนี้สำหรับ total distance ระหว่าง amino acid อย่างไร? มี
correspondence แบบ one-to-one ระหว่าง distance เหล่านี้ใน tetrahedral lattice step กับ Euclidean
distance และคุณเห็นว่าฉันคำนวณ expression บางส่วนให้คุณแล้ว
Distance เหล่านี้สามารถใช้ในการคำนวณพลังงานของ configuration
ขึ้นอยู่กับวัตถุประสงค์ คุณอาจกำหนด cutoff distance ที่ถ้าต่ำกว่านั้นถือว่า pair กำลัง interact
หรืออาจทำอะไรที่ซับซ้อนกว่า อาจไม่ชัดเจน แต่เราทำ mapping
stage เสร็จแล้วโดยการทำสิ่งนี้ State ของ qubit บ่งบอก turn และชุดของ turn กำหนด
distance ระหว่าง amino acid คู่ใด ๆ คู่ amino acid ของ species ต่าง ๆ มี
interaction ต่างกัน บางดึงดูด บางผลัก ถ้าคุณใช้ configuration และ distance เพียงแค่
กำหนดว่า amino acid interaction ที่รู้จักเปิดหรือปิด
ความแรงของสิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นที่รู้จักดี ไม่ใช่โดยฉัน แต่คุณสามารถค้นหาได้จากตารางเช่นตาราง
นี้ ดังนั้น โดยสรุปในตัวอย่างนี้ qubit ถูกใช้ mark ตำแหน่งบน lattice ซึ่งรวมกันสร้าง chain ของ amino acid
และโดยการจำลองวิธีที่พวกมัน bend และ fold เราหวังว่าจะหาผลลัพธ์ที่ดีกว่าในการวิจัยทางการแพทย์ ตอนนี้
เราข้ามวิธีคำนวณ term บางอย่างของ Hamiltonian นี้เพราะมัน hyper specific ต่อปัญหานี้ ในขณะที่การนิยาม
ทิศทางบน lattice สามารถนำไปใช้ได้ทั่วไปมากขึ้น
ตอนนี้เมื่อคุณมี Hamiltonian ทั่วไปแล้ว คุณจะต้องการแปลมันเป็น Pauli operator เสมอ ซึ่ง
native ต่อคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม นั่นคือสิ่งที่เราจะพูดถึงถัดไป
ต่อกันเลย ตอนนี้มาสำรวจวิธีแปลระบบของอนุภาคย่อยอะตอมเป็น Pauli operator อนุภาค
ย่อยอะตอมแบ่งออกเป็นสองประเภท Boson และ Fermion Boson
เช่น photon หรือ Higgs boson เป็นไปตาม statistical rule บางอย่าง และ fermion เช่น electron หรือ neutrino ก็เป็นไปตามอีกอย่าง
ความแตกต่างสำคัญระหว่างพวกมันคือ boson ได้รับอนุญาตให้อยู่ใน state เดียวกันได้ ไม่มีจำกัดว่า
boson กี่ตัวจะอยู่ใน ground state หรือ excited state ใด ๆ Fermion ในทางตรงกันข้ามเป็นนักอาจารย์ พวกมันต้องการว่า
ทุก particle มี quantum state ของตัวเอง Boson มี integer spin ในขณะที่ fermion มี half-integer
spin เช่น spin-1/2 electron หรือ exotic spin-3/2 particle เพื่อ
อธิบายระบบของ particle เราต้องการคำอธิบายพลังงานของมัน มาโฟกัสที่ fermion เราสามารถเริ่มด้วย
Hamiltonian ที่เขียนในรูปของสิ่งที่เรียกว่า creation/annihilation operator สิ่งเหล่านี้โดยพื้นฐานคือ mathematical object ที่
สอดคล้องกับการสร้างหรือทำลาย fermion จาก state ในระบบ
สิ่งเหล่านี้มักเขียนเป็น f_i dagger และ f_i ใน notation ที่เราเรียกว่า second
quantization ตอนนี้ f_i dagger คือ operator ที่สร้าง fermion ใน state i f_i คือ
operator ที่ทำลาย fermion ใน state i แต่จำไว้ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมักทำงานใน qubit
basis ด้วย rule เฉพาะสำหรับการแทน fermionic system โดยธรรมชาติพวกมันไม่ทำงานในภาษาของ
fermionic operator เพื่อเชื่อม gap นี้ เราต้อง map second quantized notation เป็น Pauli operator ซึ่ง
สอดคล้องกับ quantum gate ตามธรรมชาติ
มีการ transform หลายอย่างสำหรับ fermion ทางเลือกทั่วไปคือ Jordan-Wigner transformation
Bravyi-Kitaev และ parity mapping เป็น encoding ที่ใหม่กว่าสำหรับ fermionic encoding
Bosonic operation ในทางตรงกันข้ามสามารถแปลงได้โดยใช้ Holstein-Primakoff transformation หรือ mapping โดยตรง
Fock state ไปยัง sub-basis ของ bosonic mode ที่มี
และยังมีตัวเลือกอื่นสำหรับ boson ด้วย encoding อื่น ๆ ยังถูกวิจัย actively อยู่ แต่ตอนนี้ เรา
จะโฟกัสที่ Jordan-Wigner transform เท่านั้น
แล้วทำไมเราไม่แค่ assign qubit หนึ่งตัวแทน electron หนึ่งตัว? เพราะทำไม่ได้
qubit สามารถแยกแยะได้ แต่ electron แยกแยะไม่ได้ ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถ label และระบุ qubit แต่ละตัวบน
อุปกรณ์ได้ง่าย แต่การ indistinguishability ของ electron หมายความว่าเราไม่สามารถ label มันได้เลย เราต้อง label
แทน operator ตาม occupied orbital เช่น 1s 2s และ 2p
แทน electron เฉพาะ ดังนั้นเราต้อง label operator ตาม occupied orbital เช่น 1s
2s และ 2p แทนการ label electron เฉพาะ ดังนั้นแต่ละ qubit ทำหน้าที่
ประมาณเป็น orbital ในโมเลกุล ซึ่งถูกครอบครองหรือไม่ถูกครอบครอง
แต่วิธีที่เราทำสิ่งนั้นจริง ๆ ซับซ้อนกว่านิดหน่อย ดังนั้นตอนนี้เราแนะนำสิ่งที่เรียกว่า Jordan-Wigner mapping เพื่อติดตาม
anti-symmetry และให้แน่ใจว่า statistics ที่ถูกต้องของ fermionic system โดยรวมถูก obey Jordan
Wigner mapping เข้าใจง่ายเพราะ one-to-one correlation ระหว่าง orbital และ qubit มี
mapping อื่น ๆ ที่ accomplish เป้าหมายคล้ายกัน รวมถึง parity mapping
การคำนวณ parity ของ state ต้องการพิจารณา qubit หลายตัว ใน parity mapping และอื่น ๆ การ
interpret qubit หนึ่งตัวสอดคล้องกับ orbital หนึ่งตัวไม่ถือว่าใช้ได้
ตอนนี้มาดูตัวอย่างค่อนข้างง่ายด้วยกันเพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าเราเข้าใจ transformation นี้
สมมติว่าต้องการคำนวณ single qubit interaction f dagger f เราเริ่มด้วย plug in นิยามของ
raising และ lowering operator จากนั้นเราสามารถจัดกลุ่ม term โดย factor ออก identity matrix I และ 1/4
อย่างที่เห็น เราได้ term ที่จะคุ้นเคยสำหรับผู้ที่จัดการกับ commutation relation term นี้ใน
วงเล็บไม่ใช่อะไรนอกจาก i * commutator ของ X และ Y และ
อย่าลืม identity ที่เราเอาออกมา
จำไว้ว่าสิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นแค่ Pauli matrix ดังนั้น commutator นั้นเป็นที่รู้จักดี commutator ของ X และ Y ใน
ลำดับนั้นง่ายมาก มันคือ 2iZ ระวังอย่าทำหาย negative sign และคุณจะได้สิ่งนี้เป็น
ผลสุดท้าย ในตอนท้าย เราเขียน fermionic expression ใหม่ได้สำเร็จใน
รูปของ Pauli operator ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมของเราจะสามารถเข้าใจได้
มาพูดถึงวิธี implement Jordan-Wigner mapping ใน Qiskit กันสั้น ๆ เพราะแม้ฉันคิดว่ามัน
สำคัญที่ต้องเข้าใจวิธี mapping และ transformation ที่คล้ายกันทำงาน และเห็นมันดำเนิน
อย่างน้อยหนึ่งครั้ง คุณก็ไม่อยากทำ calculation นี้ด้วยมือทุกครั้งอยู่แล้ว
โดยเฉพาะสำหรับระบบขนาดใหญ่ เราสามารถใช้ sparse Pauli op function ใน Qiskit เพื่อ
สร้าง Pauli operation ที่เกี่ยวข้องจาก mapping ได้ง่าย implementation ที่ไม่ optimal
จะใช้ nested loop และใช้โค้ดประมาณ 20 บรรทัด
ฉันจะลิงก์โค้ดให้คุณทุกคนสำรวจ แต่ระดับสูง ขั้นตอนมีดังนี้
หนึ่ง ใช้ sparse Pauli ops from list function เพื่อสร้าง identity operator
ที่สอดคล้องกับขนาดของ parameter space ที่จะ map สอง ตาม นิยามของ creation
และ annihilation operator ที่แสดงก่อนหน้า ใช้ sparse Pauli ops from list function เพื่อนิยาม X, Y และ Z Pauli
operation สิ่งนี้จะ map fermionic creation และ annihilation operator ไปยัง qubit spin operator ที่ encode fermionic
occupation number ลงใน computational basis ของ qubit และสาม สร้าง desired
Hamiltonian ใน Pauli basis โดย apply operator ด้านบนกับ orbital ที่สนใจ โดยทั่วไปสอดคล้องกับ
การสร้าง identity matrix ที่แทน core ซึ่งเป็น non-interacting orbital จากนั้น apply creation
และ annihilation operator ไปยัง active space ด้วย weight ที่สอดคล้องกับสิ่งเฉพาะของปัญหา
อย่างที่พูดถึง นี่เป็นแค่ breakdown ระดับสูง โค้ดไม่ได้ซับซ้อนมาก และตอนนี้คุณควร
มีความมั่นใจในการปรับมันสำหรับปัญหาอื่น ๆ ที่สนใจ
ตอนนี้เราเข้าใจ Jordan-Wigner mapping scheme อย่างเต็มที่แล้ว มาดูมันในการทำงานใน setup ที่ซับซ้อนขึ้น คุณ
อาจจำงานวิจัยนี้จากตอนก่อนด้วย เรื่อง hadron dynamics ฉันจะไม่ทบทวนงานวิจัยนั้นอีกในเชิงลึก แต่กรุณาดู
ตอนก่อนถ้าพลาดและอยากรู้ ในตัวอย่างนี้ Jordan-Wigner mapping ถูกใช้เพื่อ
express Hamiltonian ของ lattice site ที่มี L sites สำหรับ Schwinger model ใน ไม่มีสนามไฟฟ้า ที่นี่
ยากกว่ามากที่จะระบุว่า qubit หนึ่งตัวแทนอะไรในแบบจำลองนี้ เพราะมันเป็นแค่
collection ของ qubit รวมกันที่ทำให้เป็นสิ่งที่จับต้องได้ทางฟิสิกส์ ในบริบทนี้คือ wave packet แทนที่นั้น คุณสามารถ
คิดคร่าว ๆ ว่า qubit เป็นชิ้นส่วนที่ discretize ของพื้นที่ ที่ L คือ lattice volume ซึ่งแต่ละ element หรือ
unit cell ประกอบด้วย qubit สอง fermionic operator ที่เราเห็นในสไลด์ก่อน อธิบาย amplitude ของ
wave function ที่ site เฉพาะ
ดังนั้น Hamiltonian ของเราประกอบด้วย fermionic raising และ lowering operator เหล่านี้ แต่เพื่อ implement
Hamiltonian ดังกล่าวบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เราต้อง express มันในรูปของ spin operator ไม่ใช่ fermionic operator
ดังนั้นเราใช้ Jordan-Wigner transformation หลังจาก apply Jordan-Wigner transformation แล้ว Hamiltonian ใหม่ของเรา
กลายเป็น equation นี้ที่ด้านล่างของสไลด์ ที่ sigma plus คือ Pauli operator X + iY และ sigma
minus คือ X - iY เมื่อเรามี Hamiltonian ที่เขียนในรูปแบบนี้แล้ว
ส่วนที่ยากของ mapping stage ก็เสร็จแล้วและสามารถเขียนเป็น circuit ใน Pauli operator ได้ง่าย
โดยสรุป เราพูดถึงสี่ตัวอย่างของวิธีที่เทคนิค mapping เฉพาะถูกใช้เมื่อเร็ว ๆ นี้ใน
สาขา quantum computing เริ่มจากที่ง่ายที่สุดและค่อย ๆ ขึ้นไปถึงการ apply Jordan-Wigner transform กับ
Hadron dynamics ฉันรู้ว่านี่มีเยอะมาก เนื้อหานี้ technical มาก
และถ้าไม่เคยเห็นมาก่อน อาจน่ากลัวมาก ข่าวดีคือฉันสัญญาว่ามันจะง่ายขึ้นและ
คุ้นเคยขึ้นยิ่งใช้เวลาฝึกฝนมากขึ้น และนั่นคือชื่อของเกมและเหตุผลที่ฉันตั้งชื่อซีรีส์ทั้งหมดว่า
Quantum Computing in Practice
ไม่ใช่สิ่งที่ใครจะรับและวิ่งต่อได้ตั้งแต่แรก ต้องการการศึกษา
การขบคิด และอาจมีบางช่วงที่หงุดหงิด แต่ฉันขอให้ทุกคนอยู่กับความไม่สบายใจและ
สำรวจคำถามที่เกิดขึ้นอย่างจริงจังขณะคุณดำเนินต่อไป เพราะนี่คือวิธีเดียวที่จะเรียนรู้จริง ๆ ขอบคุณที่
ดู นี่คือตอนที่ 5 ของ quantum computing in practice ครั้งหน้าเราจะสำรวจวิธีจำลอง
Hamiltonian ตั้งแต่ต้น เจอกันเร็ว ๆ นี้